hello everyone and like we've announced
in the previous video this is the first
ever game uh where the evans gambit was
employed or
uh well should i say sort of employed as
there there's also a game that was
played
three years prior to this game where the
evans gambit was also played between
these two gentlemen between william
davies evans and
the irish master uh alexander mcdonnell
uh however that game
was not actually the evans gambit but it
kind of transposed into the evidence
gambit so we're going to show that game
as well
but it's important to show this one this
one was uh from london uh
1829 and the one that we're going to
show after this one is london 1826
uh uh when uh william davies evans
became a ship captain and he he traveled
to london
now there's a there's a couple of very
interesting things i'm going to mention
about that
after the game but first now let's check
out the game as it is very exciting so
uh william davies evans the inventor of
the evans gambit uh
opens with e4 as one might you know
expect
we have e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to c4
now we have bishop to c5 the joko piano
is on the board
and of course now it's no no mystery
that the evans gambit
is on the board now in the game that was
played three years
uh prior to this game castles was played
and then this was met with the d6 and b4
and after uh all the usual stuff the
game transposed into the evans gambit
but
uh so i don't know if this is actually
the evans gambit the original game
or the one three years before this one
but we're going to show both so you guys
you know and know what's happening so b4
the evans gambit is officially on the
board for the for the first time uh we
have bishop captures on b4 uh
we always mention that it's a it's not
another
great to capture with the knight because
then you just allow white complete
development in the center c3 kicks away
the knight and then d4 with an attack on
the bishop
so bishop captures and b4 best way of ex
of refuting the evidence gambit is by
accepting it
c3 and now uh usually if this was a
modern game we either see bishop a5
bishop d6 or bishop to e7 what we would
not see
is bishop c5 because this is exactly
what happens uh
well even if you capture with the knight
so this is not a great square for the
bishop
however in those days uh you didn't
really know
no such things there were no opening
books there were no you know uh
you know databases online and so on
so here while you could strike
immediately with the d4
here uh evans goes for castles we have
knight to f6
now preparing the castle also but of
course white will not allow this
we have d4 e captures and now c capture
so now you see the full problem of the
bishop being on c5
white now has a spectacular central
control here
uh d4 comes with tempo or rather seek
afters and d4 comes with tempo you have
to move the bishop and
when this is played now black still
doesn't get the castle because white has
e5 and this is something that will
happen quite often in the italian game
if you if you fail to play d6 at some
point
so e5 and now black needs to decide what
to do with your knight uh well you could
move it let's say 94 but then
just queen to e2 and the knight has
nowhere to go you'd have to go for
something like d5 and then he captures
and d6 alpha song
bishop to f5 defending and now knight c3
just pile up on the knight here and it's
not possible to defend the knight you
could try something like
castles and after capture spinning the
knight but this doesn't work because
here y just goes all out with bishop
captures an f7 check
king captures and now queen to c4 check
and once the king moves to fade bishop
a3
and well you're just completely lost
here there's there's no defense against
pawn captures here
you might try some ideas let's say
captures but then just knight captures
uh attacking the rook again threatening
some nasty discoveries
also threatening queen f7 checkmate so
nothing
of course you have to prevent checkmate
but then just knight captures on b7
uh wins the queen uh easy game for white
so this
is only one of the things that can
happen if you play knight to e4
so here uh mcdonald played the d5
blocking the bishop
and now we have uh captures on f6 uh we
have d
captures on c4 and now rook to e1 with
check asking black do you want to block
with the bishop or do you want to play
king to f8
now blocking with the bishop looks nice
but the problem is after something like
captures and this and attacking the
queen
knight c3 and d5 is coming and there is
a really no good defense against this
for example queen d6 you're just going
to go knight to c3
and now this is coming there's no no
defense against that the bishop prevents
black from castling you also cannot go
here with the king
so you might try capturing this but then
just knight e4 and now knight f6 is
coming the queen is under attack
everything just uh
uh you know gets destroyed captures
captures
for example queen to c6 getting out of
harm's way but now knight f6
check and after king e7 you can capture
with uh
with a double check then you can do
pretty much whatever you like you can
trade queens move the knight promote the
pawn and so on
so really uh nothing good happens if you
play bishop to e6 here so king to f8 by
mcdonald
and now bishop to a3 with check with
king the g8 and
now striking in the center with d5
so again if you don't want to lose
material you have to move knight a5 and
now comes
bishop to e7 attacking the queen
and the defending the the f6 pawn so the
queen has to move we have queen to d7
and now f captures uh sorry f captures
on g7
with an attack on the rook uh of course
you need to capture this
king captures and g7 is played and now
queen to d2
and now queen to g5 is coming so you
need to you need to prevent this
uh and here uh there is uh uh this
position has actually been reached in
2016 where black tried h6 and still lost
terribly
uh however uh here in those days in 1829
we have queen the g4
now guarding against this uh
quinta g5 check idea and it is also as
of move 16 that this position has never
been reached again
however uh now the position is still
completely lost for black and
william davies evans uh the the the
great uh
inventor of the evans gambit goes queen
to c3 with
check and now there's a problem the
bishop guards these two squares the
queen completely
controls this diagonal so you might uh
go back or you might
you know try some uh you know just
running with the king if you go sound
like king to h6 then bishop to g5 is
coming
and there's not much you can do for
example here king g6
king h6 bishop g5 check you're gonna go
king somewhere
but if you go here then it's just check
king moves and it's just a very nice
check mate you you can go king h5 queen
capture sun f7 is checkmate as the
bishop and knight
nicely control these two squares so here
after queen to c3
check mcdonald went king to g8 but now
now there's an even bigger problem we've
reached a position from the thumbnail
and you know what that means
uh feel free to pause the video and find
the incredible mating three
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
brilliant queen sacrifice and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's yes queen capture sun h8 uh getting
the king
in front of the check and then uh then
just moving the bishop so rook to e8 can
deliver checkmate very simple stuff
so queen captures with check everything
completely forced only movie's king
captures on h8
now bishop to f6 check only move king to
g8 or you can block with the queen
doesn't really help if the queen blocks
it's still rook to a8 checkmate you do
not go after the queen
but here mcdonald went king to g8 and
now rook to e8 is
checkmate uh and well now there's just
uh nothing not nothing more to be done
here
so really really incredible stuff uh now
whether this is the first game where the
evans gambit was employed or the one in
1826 we're going to show both of them
as this one is some say that this one it
wasn't an
actual game that this was more of an
analysis between evans and mcdonnell
but the one from 1826 where the position
transposed into the evidence gambit was
was definitely a game so we're going to
show that one
but just in case uh you know you you
guys don't consider that to be the
actual evidence game but then you can
also
uh you know uh talk to your friends at
the bar at the library about
this one uh but yeah also one fun fact
that i
uh found on wikipedia about the william
davies evans um
as he was a ship captain he was also an
inventor and his most famous invention
was the
three color the lighting on the naval
vessels uh
designed to prevent collisions at night
for this invention he was awarded
1500 pounds by the british government
and a gold
uh chronometer
and 200 pounds from the tsar of russia
so really really incredible stuff i
tried googling this to really
understand what i mean i i understand
what this invention is i just couldn't
find the actual one so
if any of you is a ship captain you know
do write in the comments what
what this is actually so we can you know
all increase our vast knowledge
and also if you've noticed lately i'm
i'm really running out of quotes to use
above the board i will start you know
using them all the way from the
beginning as i should
but you are more than welcome to you
know reply to this video with a
hashtag quote and then you know uh
suggest your favorite quote i'm gonna
uh once uh i wake up tomorrow let's say
i'm gonna filter
this entire video with the hashtag quote
filter and then i'm going to
use all of your quotes save them for
later and i'm going to be using your
favorite quotes maybe by your
favorite philosopher or your favorite
you know
artist or singer or or movie star or you
know just a
athlete you know just anything uh so you
can you can you
feel free to suggest quotes so we can
use uh that as well
uh so yeah that's uh the game uh the
so-called first ever game where the
evans gambit was played between these
two gentlemen
uh i do hope you enjoyed it like i said
we're going to cover the other one as
well
uh i would like to thank uh chiro de
simon uh alan erickson
uh jessie you so ali elliot joseph and
boris kogan for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the good stuff
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
see you soon with
the one that was played before this one
have an excellent rest of your day